you want to do mono first sure yeah get
ready to say everything we ever said at
the monologue meetings cancel time
behind the nasa stay tuned
yesterday was daylight savings time
when uh yeah
daylight savings time when we lose an
hour for no apparent reason yeah
by the way losing an hour for no
apparent reason is also the motto for
this show and we've always
hey conan o'brien here andy richter uh
for another edition of behind the
nonsense
where we um we look behind the scenes
today we're going to focus uh a little
bit on the monologue process
specifically the meetings that we would
have just before the show would tape
figure out which jokes to do
and often it was a very chaotic and uh
hilarious mess
that meeting uh joining me laurie
kilmartin hilarious uh comedy writer uh
brian kylie occasionally no always
hilarious
uh you know you're no kill martin but
you're good um i don't know what to say
but we get into this very small room and
this went on for years and years and
years and it's your dressing room my
dressing room so it's your space it's
myspace we're getting ready the audience
is just on the other side of the wall
sometimes loading in sometimes the band
is playing we're getting very close to
show time
and time is of the essence and we're
looking through a big stack of jokes and
then absolute inappropriate foolishness
would it wreck well you describe it i
think it's it's so interesting that to
to get to the place where you can tell
these really clean jokes on television
you have to go to a place where you're
just saying unrepeatable things in the
green room yeah just to get yourself
there you just identified what it is
lori and brian are both very good
excellent stand-up comedians you guys
understand something about this
performing process i'm pretty stressed
out i have a 10 year old son
and already at age 10 we've had multiple
discussions on masturbation etiquette
at 10 years old i was like please do not
knock on mom's door when she's
masturbating
there is something
about
needing to stretch it all the way out
here to then pull it back to here so the
jokes would be
you know jokes that you can tell on
television about the president or
a celebrity or what happened in the news
today you would push me i would push you
we would stretch it way out and be doing
entire riffs
that talk about canceled yeah the whole
point was that you were going to be
really clean in about five minutes yeah
yeah and that was that's what was so
hilarious but it's also too i always
look at it as like we ran an opium den
for tourists and we could only get off
on the really hard stuff go ahead have
this weak sauce but for us
i gotta put poison right in my veins
before i feel anything i remember one of
the first meetings out here
andy was late and you guys got in a fake
yelling argument of where were you i was
around the corner around the corner
fudge is made and it became this
about what was that rhyme and what it
looked like
but it's 20 minutes
every second is precious we're supposed
to get out there and do this show but we
would get started uh on milk milk
lemonade yeah milk lemonade around the
corner and brian you go back to 93 or
early 90s
okay so you're you know really pretty
much a lifer you came on the show and
you didn't know really know what to
expect and you thought well conan's
probably this erudite like all you knew
is that oh he went to a good college
absolutely it's like oh he says harvard
whatever and then it was like oh my god
this is totally but i mean we had a
meeting where we were talking about
jokes and i said one thing but then i
pretended you had a candle there for
some reason and you lit the candle and
then you had a bottle scotch and you
pretended to knock the candle over in
the scotch and then you pretended to
catch on fire and then you were going
out the window and somehow the curtain
wrapped around your neck it was like
this long and then i hung myself as i
burned and i acted it all out and
brian's sitting there this has nothing
to do with the show
and then you got a very different idea
of it was like my first day and i'm like
okay
this is not what i was perfect this is
uh this is not going to be dick cavett
and i remember also there was one of my
first days that was we were trying to
decide between this joke or that joke
and you stopped somebody in the hall and
said what do you think of this joke on a
scale of one to ten ten being the
funniest two not being funny three being
funny again and then you just went yeah
yeah it's super complicated it was an
intern the interim was like wait what's
four no there is no four there's three
and then five five is great but four is
off and
and what i love too is at the beginning
of that you really wanted an answer but
then you discovered like oh no there's
this other thing that i want much more
which is to [ __ ] with this kid yeah you
know i want to really have a good time
yeah your laugh is so fantastic and uh
fantastic yeah the kill martin cackle
could call it
but uh
you would we would be inappropriate and
you then you would like push us much
farther sometimes i remember that very
clearly yes like for sure we were always
grateful when uh someone was saying
earlier gavin pallone would stop in
because he also had a great laugh as
much as we knew the mono wasn't like our
best effort and it's like please don't
let gavin be there today and save so
gavin's my manager and he would come by
always wearing a track suit a full
full track suit head to toe matching
yeah matching track suit but he's got a
really good sense of humor he'd sit
there and he would laugh really hard and
the rest of us get so jaded like
there's not a lot of laughter in that
room yeah and then gavin would come in
and then he would usually try and think
of some money-making scheme
he would say you know you could take
that joke you could try and make it a
sitcom and then i could produce it and
we're like shut up after a while working
on a show like this there is a lot of
like oh yeah that's really funny you
know you don't you don't laugh at things
but you're like oh yeah yeah that's
really funny evan and sona often save
jokes yes well sona my assistant uh god
lover she was a good laugher but she
really liked jokes that had weed in them
um
dick jokes dick jokes yeah and she'd be
like ha
and i'd be like no i'm not gonna and you
guys would say like see it's worth doing
the
crap
had too much uh weed and then his dick
got big i'm like that's not a joke you
should be like
dick and then of course my manager would
be like you know actually what we could
do
you could market something that makes
your penis larger uh using marijuana our
jokes could never compete with the rifts
that was the problem in the room
you'd do blue kylie or something and
kill and then we'd go to the jokes and i
was like i would spend
20 minutes doing an impression of brian
kylie we always call my grandfather
poppy um
because of his
opium addiction
i can impersonate brian kelly uh doing
his jokes and his mannerisms and it's
very um i would do this routine where
it's kylie and a club going incredibly
blue
filthy blue i can't even say it right
here but just
just the dirtiest thing you've ever
heard the dirtiest thing that red fox
ever said times 10 and it's kylie doing
that and killing and then riding home in
his tiny little conservative car and
then reading a truman biography in his
bed and then getting called to go back
and
go back to the club yeah and um so i'm
uh i'm not i'm with my uh with my old
lady i told her you've got on you've got
to wash that ass
if i'm going to uh go down there and uh
you know service you in that area you
need to clean that [ __ ] ass you see i
don't know why that stuff would just we
would do it we'd be crying and then i
was like all right let's go do this tv
show yeah there's a new trend where
people watch television that they
despise
and it's called hate
watching hate watching yeah
speaking of hate watching hi mom
all right well uh you got an idea of
what we were talking about
i never want to see either of you